[Musik]
das ist pure day frau mit afro homicide
interessant die reportage vorher noch
nie mit dem thema in kontakt
ich finde es spannend dass ich einen
üblichen
irene verborgene welt über wochen afrika
wie bischof das thema und was ich danach
der reportage und stern stehen darin
liegt lieber war er überrascht
mit meiner kollegin alle sie sage ich ja
in dem film mit und mich hat überrascht
dass zu mini spielfeld mit einer
chemischen mittel tropft verbrannt hat
oder evtl
natürlich
so lang braucht bis sie ihre haarpracht
und
schönbrodt hat das hat mich beeindruckt
und überrascht war zum heulen schön es
ist so schön dass wir die auch
schweizerinnen endlich gesehen und
gehört werden
ich wurde auch diskriminiert habe
deswegen meine haare mit relaxen und
braid unwiderruflich beschädigt meine
tochter werde ich nie die haare relaxen
ich merke schon dass klasse sicher auch
hier ist ziel sei dass man die
geschichte womöglich stärker wird ich
finde es total schön wenn man dadurch
einen identifizieren 200 franken 48 h
wegpunkt mir extrem wenig wie für hunde
wohnung wieder ursprünglichen horst
andrina und ist der handel mit nicht nur
extrem problematisch die eigene hand
über die ordensträger und damit sie dann
für das
sind für mich unglaublich brutal der
infotisch durchaus berechtigt und ich
finde das super spannendes thema die
tour geht es nur ein paar
kollegen zu indien christ water gemacht
hat der zeigt sie wie hinduistische frau
aus religiösen gründen er spendet der
großteil seiner akteure mit dem sinn da
haben wir nur ein kommentar
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass ihr auch
junkel in die doku genommen hätten denn
die betrifft genau so zumindest kann ich
von mir selbst sprechen von kleinen habe
ich gelernt dass meine haare mit großem
schmerz verbunden sind physisch von
kämmen oder psychisch doch andere kinder
die einen deswegen meine haare goldin
schon immer nur als schön wenn sie
geflochten wurden gestrickt oder anders
als ein afro auch fühle ich mich immer
noch komisch mit auf rhode auszugehen
ich habe immer eine baseball mütze oder
eine oder andere messen er sei befinde
dass der rat wenn ich das so liest es
ist kraut das ist eine betrifft und ich
hoffe du hast trotzdem
besuchen
ich habe mich bewusst übernahm leo frau
konzentriert mir das wichtigste sich die
geschichte vollständig wie möglich hoffe
zähler ich würde mir wünschen dass bald
jede person ab jetzt frau oder mann
egal mit welcher frisur
florence schrieb
produktmanager und hatte auch ohne dass
chemische spritzmittel pro mini hochhuth
mega verbrannt hat aber ich muss ehrlich
sagen auf druck gebracht ist nie ganz
offen sondern haben sie im metall- und
bundes will ich so oft das lachen
das kenne ich von mega fehlenden frauen
ich selber finde dass man einfach das
war auch deshalb ist die passieren dass
man nicht einfach so ins haar ihnen laut
das ist einfach
der kulturellen ich interessant finde
ich allerdings dass in deutschland
derzeit gerade eine diskussion über
kulturelle aneignung läuft dort werden
unter anderem welche kritisiert die sich
dreadlocks machen lassen ist das
aufsetzen von vixs nicht dass bordeaux
und dazu ja tatsächlich sehr kontroverse
diskussion
ist es nicht der fall wir reden alle von
der kulturelle ereignisse als
mehrheitsgesellschaft eps von der
unterdrückte
minderheit aspekt nahm nun das war's
aber nichts also es ist einfach zeit
das ist mit einem mix und der a und d
mark nicht der fall
über diskriminiere geredet schwarz ich
übergriff wo verletzten kosten und sehr
stark negativ behaftet ist schwarz ist
da so nicht meint wenn wir von schwarz
rechts dann ist es selbst bezeichnet
ein weiterer unproblematische begriff
weert be puck also dreiecke indisches
und and people of colour
umständlich und es ist ja nicht so
bekannt darum habe ich mich für die
begriffe schwarz entschieden
und
ist
[Musik]
deshalb viel
psychisch bin ich wollte unbedingt mit
aufschwung statement regierung immer
darauf sogar
möglich zeigen
und sitte dokumentation mögliche heilung
wenn ich mal aufstand sage ich mag es
mit 40 minuten
hart flinke dem legalisierten lieben
helden aber ich hab dort noch stand und
wie ist das wort formieren muss nicht
wird sich stimmigen wird also das finde
ich bin dabei besonders einfach macht
und unterdrückung ist unterwegs aber es
hat dann ein kritischer kommentar geht
aus der cdu nun hauptsache migräne
selbstwertgefühl was sagst du zu dämmen
aus gott da wirklich um st
also ich finde man gesellschaft ein so
viele dann sind wir doch alle
gesellschafter bis für andere das hat
mir das selbstwertgefühl wenn sie begann
sie gesagt wird hektischer wurde und was
ich nicht denn ich das doch eine
natürliche reaktion
ja ich finde alle frauen in einer
dokumentation sind extrem ähnlich sie
sind nicht nur
wenigen aktie vor der kamera das braucht
extrem film und extrem für sein stil
zu dem abschluss stehe ich bin froh wenn
ich das gefühl jetzt überholen ja also
wer immer das gefühl und
im gegensatz zu auch froh stelle ich mir
die
fluchten johr 8 und praktisch wenn man
sich zum beispiel größe leid und dann
sondern drucken hat stimmt nicht
[Applaus]
ich sage also ich finde es sehr gut die
serie und mir die haare sehr gut macht
damit dieses gar nix für die meisten
liegt das wider was die airways ist gar
nicht bewusst dass
das quartett eine harte knochen
irgendwas ist versteckt sondern es geht
darum zum schützen also es ist natürlich
wie viel meter hin warum muss richtig
macht es tut mit active health
teilnehmer da sie immer das ist ein
projekt das teil bleibe da ist es haben
und dem kran das schiff und andere
frucht und hat einfach viel viel
intensität produkte zu denen das hat
auch gewisse sache wurde zur kirche da
fragt auch viele geile hast du auch
wissen alle das gefühl anderen
briefträger als einfach da auch froh ja
zum beispiel im schaffen kann karl
direkt an russland und den hartz iv
sätze hat das zusammenfinden und meine
ich das einfach schwierig je nachdem was
ich jetzt endlich los die halbrunde es
gab aber sich zum teil weil ich so viel
haben sowieso alles fließt im netz
bringen
jetzt hat immer weniger aber ich habe
wie man hat verständlich sind wir damit
auch spielen und so gleichzeitig danke
ich bin es auch schön wenn ich natürlich
frustriert und richtig
das ist fifa kommentar und wenn schon
dann abonniert doch der kanal